[Applause]
alright what's up guys it is a Friday
afternoon now it's super excited about
today because we are doing a danger boys
screening at UC Irvine later today
there'll be my first time going to a
screening barton choke previously have
screen danger boys at Boston I wasn't
able to make it to that one this being
more local to me thank me Steve Bartow
and a few other guys from JK are all
coming out and we're gonna have a good
time it's always exciting to screen
something because in front of an
audience because you're wondering if
people will laugh or react in the places
where you design it to be laughed at
super excited I just got back from my
therapy I've been doing a lot of therapy
lately and working on myself you know
what growing up I never thought I'd ever
be the kind of guy to go to therapy but
therapy was only for people that are
broken and I'm not quite sure what
marriage a person to be broken honestly
but I guess if that's the case and I
guess I am broken but aren't we all
right and me and TIFF did couples
therapy for a little bit as well and
then lately now I'm just working on
myself
and I've come to realize the more I work
on myself the more I'm actually working
on our relationship for our relationship
I know Tiff's talked about on JK news
and mentioned it in like the big mood
podcast shout out the big mood podcast
because I'm actually in an episode where
I we we actually do talk about a
relationship it's not a mystery that you
know me and TIFF have gone through our
you know share of up and downs
throughout our relationship and then
2019 was probably probably the roughest
and then all throughout that time we've
been you know doing therapy like all
2019
I think after our Iceland trip back last
March we came back and we started doing
therapy and recently though I feel like
we are finally out of that muck that
depression that loneliness whatever you
like you know when when you get really
down you're in your muck it's you don't
really see that you know the light at
the end of the tunnel and I I can gladly
say we are finally at the end of the
tunnel if anything is I I feel that
great about our relationship what I've
learned for our relationship was that I
as a person and very very introverted so
introverted that I generally don't find
a safe space and talking to anyone and
what that does is I don't necessarily
open up a hundred percent even if I'm
telling them something about myself I'll
say it in a way where I don't give them
my full emotional value you know like
I'll never be truly excited about
something even if I was because I have a
hard time getting to a place where I'm
vulnerable enough to show you my 100%
like emotion like right now I'm trying
to I'm ecstatic that in our relationship
is doing good but I'm you know it's it's
a let's pulled back I imagine with what
it's read being read on the camera and
this wasn't just my relationship with
TIFF but it's also my relationship with
everyone that I know I I tend to you
know I'm a very muted person I have a
hard time sharing things about myself
which vlogging actually has been kind of
therapeutic over the years there
blogging and in and of itself has you
know it's it's it's good side which is
you know it's good practice for me to
just talk I'm the kind of guy that I can
sit in a room and just stare at everyone
else and be content like I don't have
the safe word but when it comes to
having relationships not just with a
wife but with a son with my own parents
because I also was very shielded away
from my parents and then like my friends
my best friends you know and JK people
people that you know grew up
we've had my guards up in terms of truly
opening up being at home and at ease you
know there's always a tenseness with me
so that's something I'm really working
on and therapy has helped a lot back to
the physical world we are now I'm
waiting for TIFF she's upstairs getting
ready we are about to head out to see
the house because the house is almost
done yeah and then next couple of days
we're gonna probably start clearing out
all the stuff that's in here the wife he
is ready are you ready to go through the
house Oh what does that pose I like your
new clothes by the way thank you they're
from pop flicks
oh it's matching inside up there and
down there oh I see I see when are we
moving into your house I mean we don't
really know yet either like for sure we
don't know because they keep moving the
dates on us but the most recent updated
date is between February 6 and the 14th
we will get our keys we're gonna be a
fit you can finally call his mom and dad
officially I feel like they know I mean
mom and dad we just haven't been
property-owners
yeah we got to be property owners to be
mom and dad oh that's true
my mom and dad were there were always
property owners yeah my I'm iodine girl
I grew up in apartments and stuff I
never really thought of like us owning
property growing up so I see to me it's
like cool I get to improve my childhood
for my kids childhood that's that's the
that's the pattern right that's the
that's what we all strive for is to
create a better better than our parents
and to create a better childhood for our
kids when I look at Isaac and like I
think about his whole life I'm like damn
I wish I was my mom man I wish I was
raising me so cool imagine all this
stuff Isaac's been able to experience
like if I got to experience that when I
was
kid I'm being selfish and stuff thinking
like that but I don't know I just kind
of I think every parent kind of goes
through that where they they provide a
better childhood for their children than
what they had and then I think every
single one they just don't talk about it
they're secretly like I wish I raised me
I am giving myself like my kid a better
tellin ya you can't pamper your kids the
way you would have wanted to be pampered
as a kid we're not just chamfered but
like parented at least parented ya the
right kind of tough love and the right
kind of discipline that actually reaches
you know that would have reached you at
that time right like like communication
and understanding and explaining the
world but I guess you're really good at
that by the way thank you you explain a
lot like you you tackle all that what
you do you tackle all the tough subject
puberty safe sex dating I'm gonna have
to list though everything you won't be
here all day
I really am raising Isaac how I wish I
was raised so it's coming from a selfish
place not even it's not even about Isaac
it's never about Isaac that looks tight
you gotta keep your hair now cuz you've
been talking about getting rid of the
blue hair but this is so cool matches
your hair really transform the house
[Applause]
we got a driveway car all you want to
tile
[Music]
[Applause]
it looks so good I was scared as gonna
be darker but it's actually really late
in the bathtub
I actually really love my pores
I'm happy there I forget all the colors
are you picked already you can't tell
[Music]
[Music]
its driveway day for everybody I see it
very slowly very slowly
[Music]
all right so I am finally at UCI UC
Irvine and just got to the green room it
seems like they've gotten some snacks
and they know it's very well because as
a group
JK loves their Japanese snacks it seems
like I'm the first one here and waiting
for Bart and Jo and whoever else is
coming we are minutes away from the
danger boy screening I just realized
it's the first time I've ever screened
anything where I'm gonna be on stage
talking about it too I don't know why
I'm getting nervous all of a sudden are
you guys feeling about this screening
I'm excited yeah you've a bigger crowd
excited by Fonda to share 500
[Applause]
so much for coming out and also
minorities in yeah don't bootleg it when
somebody steps up to you and they will
get you even [ __ ]
our warrior
I'm bid I'm the leader of the danger
boys yeah
[Music]
thanks for having us thank you guys for
having us
[Music]
[Music]